cancer is a creepy and mysterious thing
in the process of trying to understand
it to get better at killing it we
discovered a biological paradox that
remains unsolved to this day
large animals seem to be immune to
cancer which doesn't make any sense
the bigger being the more cancer it
should have
to understand why we first need to take
a look at the nature of cancer itself
[Music]
our cells are protein robots made out of
hundreds of millions of parts
guided only by chemical reactions they
create and dismantle structures sustain
a metabolism to gain energy or make
almost perfect copies of themselves
we call these complex chemical reactions
pathways
they are biochemical networks upon
networks intertwined and stacked on top
of each other
most of them can barely be comprehended
by a single human mind and yet they
function perfectly
until they don't
with billions of trillions of reactions
happening in thousands of networks over
many years the question is not if
something will go wrong but when
tiny mistakes add up until the grandiose
machinery gets corrupted
to prevent this from getting out of hand
our cells have kill switches that make
them commit suicide
but these kill switches are not
infallible
if they fail a cell can turn into a
cancer cell
most of them are slain by the immune
system very quickly but this is a
numbers game given enough time a cell
will accrue enough mistakes slip by
unnoticed and begin making more of
itself
all animals have to deal with this
problem
in general the cells of different
animals are the same size the cells of a
mouse aren't smaller than yours it just
has fewer cells in total and a shorter
lifespan
fewer cells and a short life means a
lower chance of things going wrong or
cells mutating or at least it should
mean that
humans live about 50 times longer and
have 1 000 times more cells than mice
yet the rate of cancer is basically the
same in humans and in mice
even waiter blue whales with about three
thousand times more cells than humans
don't seem to get cancer at all really
this is pito's paradox the baffling
realization that large animals have much
much less cancer than they should
scientists think there are two main ways
of explaining the paradox evolution and
hypertumours
solution 1 evolve or become a blob of
cancer
as multi-cellular beings developed 600
million years ago animals became bigger
and bigger which added more and more
cells and hence more and more chances
that cells could be corrupted
so the collective had to invest in
better and better cancer defenses
the ones that did not died out but
cancer doesn't just happen it's a
process that involves many individual
mistakes and mutations in several
specific genes within the same cell
these genes are called proto-oncogenes
and when they mutate it's bad news
for example with the right mutation a
cell will lose its ability to kill
itself
another mutation and it will develop the
ability to hide another and it will send
out calls for resources another one and
it will multiply quickly
these oncogenes have an antagonist
though tumor suppressor genes
they prevent these critical mutations
from happening or order the cell to kill
itself if they decide it's beyond repair
it turns out that large animals have an
increased number of them
because of this elephant cells require
more mutations than micelles to develop
a tumor they are not immune but more
resilient
this adaption probably comes with a cost
in some form but researchers still
aren't sure what it is
maybe tumor suppressors make elephants
age quicker later in life or slow down
how quickly injuries heal we don't know
yet
but the solution to the paradox may
actually be something different
hypertumours
solution two
hypertumours yes really
hypertumors are named after
hyperparasites the parasites of
parasites hypertumours are the tumors of
tumors
cancer can be thought of as a breakdown
in cooperation normally cells work
together to form structures like organs
tissue or elements of the immune system
but cancer cells are selfish and only
work for their own short-term benefit if
they're successful they form tumors huge
cancer collectives that can be very hard
to kill
making a tumor is hard work though
millions or billions of cancer cells
multiply rapidly which requires a lot of
resources and energy
the amount of nutrients they can steal
from the body becomes the limiting
factor for growth
so the tumor cells trick the body to
build new blood vessels directly to the
tumor to feed the thing killing it
and here the nature of cancer cells may
become their own undoing
cancer cells are inherently unstable and
so they can continue to mutate some of
them faster than their buddies
if they do this for a while at some
point one of the copies of the copies of
the original cancer cell might suddenly
think of itself as an individual again
and stop cooperating which means just
like the body the original tumor
suddenly becomes an enemy fighting for
the same scarce nutrients and resources
so the newly mutated cells can create a
hypertumor
instead of helping they cut off the
blood supply to their former buddies
which will starve and kill the original
cancer cells
cancer is killing cancer
this process can repeat over and over
and this may prevent cancer from
becoming a problem for a large organism
it is possible that large animals have
more of these hypertumors than we
realize they might just not become big
enough to notice which makes sense a two
gram tumor is ten percent of a mouse's
body weight one it's less than zero
point zero zero two percent of a human
and 0.0002
of a blue whale
all three tumors require the same number
of cell divisions and have the same
number of cells so an old blue whale
might be filled with tiny cancers and
just not care
there are other proposed solutions to
pito's paradox such as different
metabolic rates or different cellular
architecture but right now we just don't
know scientists are working on the
problem
figuring out how large animals are so
resilient to one of the most deadly
diseases we know could open the path to
new therapies and treatments
cancer has always been a challenge today
we are finally beginning to understand
it and by doing so one day we might
finally overcome it
this video was sponsored by
you
if you want to help us make more you can
do so by supporting us on patreon or
getting one of the beautiful things
we've made like our space explorer
notebook with infographic pages and
unique grids to inspire your creativity
or an infographic poster bundle or the
very comfy courtshirt hoodie or if you
missed it the first time the second run
of our gratitude journal we put a lot of
time and love into our merch because
just like with our videos we only want
to put things into the world that we
feel good about courts because out is a
project that by rights shouldn't really
work
videos like the one you just watched
take months to finish and we're only
able to put in so much time because of
your direct support because you watch
and share and because you care
thank you for watching
[Music]
you